hallo hallo heute drehen wir eine neue
folge von easy german es geht um
vorbilder
die frage ist wer oder was sind deine
vorbilder und warum es ist gerade
sonntag und ein wenig zeit in berlin als
schicken liebe grüße an paris' und
janosch die gerade in den usa sind und
dort ganz viel spaß hoffentlich haben
ich hab ja auch sehr viel spaß und
francisco und wir gucken jetzt mal für
gute antworten finden los geht's
wer oder was sind deine vorbilder also
vorbilder sind für mich menschen die in
ihrem leben ziemlich viel erreicht haben
die sich was aufgebaut haben
ja wenn man halt glücklich ist und sich
dem lebensstil angereichert hat den man
haben möchte so ganz allgemein
ich weiß nicht meine schwester und hast
du auch ein beispiel meine eltern
tatsächlich würde ich jetzt mal sagen da
angekommen wo sehen wollten und das für
mich ein vorbild und du versuchst das
auch auf jeden fall
ich würde auf jeden fall sagen meine
eltern meine große schwester
ich glaube es denn die dann schon eher
so die familiäre richtung java ist sie
eine sehr starke charakter unabhängiger
mensch ist weil sie immer alles alleine
gemacht rate ich weiß es nicht das
inspiriert mich sehr gut wahrscheinlich
vielleicht einfach auch wirklich eine
gute kindheit bei den hatte weil sie gut
nicht immer alles richtig gemacht haben
aber viel und dass man irgendwie denkt
dass man vielleicht weil man einmal groß
auf
auch so ähnlich sein kann oder sich das
als vorbild nehmen kann auf jeden fall
mein vorbild also ganz ehrlich ich habe
eigentlich gar kein sixpack disc 1 na
also könnten nicht an eine bestimmte
person denkt niemand vorbild wäre ich
denn jeder muss seinen eigenen weg gehen
du kannst du mit so einer frage mit 100
tiefgreifenden frage mich
sonntagsmorgens er wissen ich habe keine
vorbilder und wieso nicht
gute frage weil ich mir noch nie darüber
gedanken gemacht habe mögen sie
besondere charaktereigenschaften
menschen wo sie sagen wenn das ist mir
wichtig vielleicht ja schon dass leute
nicht nur um sich drehen dass sie dich
so auftrumpfen
dass sie sich andere auch kümmern dass
sie auch ein bisschen selbst hoch sind
und wer ist das das ist eine sehr
bekannte architekt der leider nicht mehr
lebt und wieso ist das sein vorbild weil
er versucht hat etwas für den menschen
aufzubauen was ja eher greifbar für
jeden sozusagen ist egal in welcher
zielgruppe du bist du konntest du damals
etwas leisten um es geht um möbelstücke
die so tragbar beziehungsweise
finanzierbar für jeden fall meine
vorbilder sind eigentlich hauptsächlich
starke frauen weil als frau ist es ja
nach wie vor noch schwierig in der
gesellschaft die eigene position zu
finden und die vorbilder fangen an von
indira gandhi über alice schwarzer auch
im deutschsprachigen raum ich denke wir
als frauen sollten unsere auch auf
frauen konzentrieren
vorbilder habe ich eigentlich gar keine
großartig so der einzige dicht an den
könnte wäre tom waits
so aber es jetzt keinen für deutsch
lernen jetzt nicht unbedingt irgendwie
geeignet und wieso ist er ein vorbild
weil er macht was er will so authentisch
ist und supermuc gemacht und ja stylish
unternehmer wie edel masken also jeff
bases die ganz großen eigentlich sowieso
weil sie große unternehmen aufgebaut
haben und viel verantwortung tragen auch
heute noch und möchtest du später zum
leben auch führen also ein großes
unternehmen führen wir verantwortung
tragen jetzt vielleicht nicht so groß
aber trotzdem verantwortung tragen
und auch ein unternehmen zu bilden das
eben potenzial hat etwas großes zu
erreichen
also mein aller größtes vorbild ist
jesus christus er glaube an ihn und er
ist mein größtes vorbild und wie
inspiriert er ihr leben durch sein wort
durch die bibel durch den heiligen geist
dazu mir spricht doch andere menschen
tatsächlich ganz spießig meine eltern
weil sie einfach ein tolles leben haben
mit sich im reinen sind und ja ganz
genau also das ist so mein vorbild was
ich für mein leben auch möchte versuche
meinen eigenen mein eigenes vorzuweisen
und ansonsten ja nee also ich habe es
irgendwie berühmte leute die meine farbe
da sind und seiner familie meine mutter
natürlich meine freunde sind meine
vorbilder ich gleich meinen freunden an
und auch meine familie würde ich sagen
weil es ist immer für einen da sind ja
welche eigenschaften findest du ein
bewundernswert oder inspirieren dass du
das auch mal versucht das so diese
eigenschaften hast immer zu sich selbst
zu stehen und sich weiterzuentwickeln
nicht zu verharrt auf seine meinung oder
so eine charaktereigenschaft zu sein
sondern versuchen sich immer weiter zu
entwickeln und was ist dir besonders
wichtig bei deinen freunden
dass sie ein akzeptieren wie du bist und
dass sie sich dass sie sich nicht
verändern wollen und das weiß nicht dass
man in harmonie miteinander zusammen
sein kann kann ich alles nennen
mein vorbild wären und wieso ja weil der
cool ist der hat nicht unbedingt
superkräfte er hat so einen geilen anzug
hat sehr viel kohle und hat alles was
man so braucht also ich glaube eine
konkrete person habe ich nicht aber
menschen generell aus dem alltag die
positiv sind die mich beeindrucken die
nehme ich mir dann auch als vorbild aber
für jede einzelne kleine sache nicht für
ein großes thema und aus meiner jugend
kindheit habe ich auch nicht jetzt ein
konkretes vorbild aber ich habe mal zu
meiner mama gesagt also was ist weil man
immer mal sein großes vorbild aber ich
habe damals diät kleiner zwerg gesagt
und wenn nicht ein vorbild an ein
abschreckendes und das ist schon albert
einstein spruch und ehrlich gesagt ja
das ist schon auch manchmal gegründet
das stimmt
[Musik]
hast du auch kindheitshelden spiderman
das war und wieso spiderman als
superheld coole fähigkeiten relativ
jungen ja genau deswegen ja detektiv
conan ist das also ein charakter
anime-serie und er war ebenso ein
detektiv da wir durch so ein kind
geworden ist dann sozusagen kinder
detektiv war
wieso war der cool weil ich ja bereits
schlau schlau schlau ist immer auch eine
gute eigenschaft auf jeden fall die man
sich als vorbild nehmen kann
naja was heißt vorbild aber eine
inspiration und tatsächlich pippi
langstrumpf pippi langstrumpf und wieso
weiß sie nicht wo er ist eine tolle frau
ist ein tolles mädchen stark und lustig
ich glaube pippi ist gerade auch fürs
erwachsenen seinem eine vorbildfunktion
in der hinsicht dass man sein herzens
weg nicht verliert das man wirklich
danach geht's was die eigene
inspirationen vision ein geben möchten
ohne sich von irgendwelchen
gesellschaftsformen beeinflussen zu
lassen angst zu bekommen oder
dergleichen so wirklich immer mut zu
bleiben und zu tun wonach ja wonach ein
bisschen steht
pippi langstrumpf es gibt so ein
italienisches zeichentrick der ist laut
ihm passiert so punkte
und wieso die beiden weil sie irgendwie
bisschen komisch an aber witzig und
süßes und wieso weil sie auch stärke
beweist und nicht in irgendeine
geschlechterrolle direkt rein passt wenn
man einfach ihr leben so lebt ob junge
oder mädchen das muss nicht fest sein
einmal winnie puuh ja genau
und wieso ja weil der warum lässig hat
sich keinen stress gemacht so muss so in
den tag hinein spaziert hat seinen honig
dessen ja auf jeden fall ein entspanntes
leben dass unsere episode zum thema
vorbilder
und ich hoffe euch haben die antworten
genauso gut gefallen wie mir ich fand es
sehr interessant und inspirierend und
hinterlasst doch einfach einen kommentar
in dem er schreibt wer oder was eure
vorbilder sind und wenn ihr noch mehr
übung machen wollt dann werdet ihr
einfach per twin und klickt ihr drauf
natürlich könnt ihr uns auch einfach
abonnieren und ein leichter lassen
stehen bleiben
ok
[Musik]
hier und schreibt mit
dennoch gut